con 16 años floyd es una de las
fundadoras del movimiento prodemocracia
su primer combate se libró en el colegio
donde luchó contra la obligación para
los alumnos de tener el pelo corto una
herencia de la dictadura militar todavía
vigente en tailandia hoy en día en junio
flow lo denunció a través de acciones de
choque en la calle
las personas creen que manifestarse es
algo agresivo pero a mí me parece que
los agresivos son estos profesores que
nos castigan cortando nos el pelo
con castigos corporales
desde que estoy llevando a cabo esta
acción los profesores no me molestan
[Música]
y hoy hace parte de un grupo llamado bar
student estudiantes rebeldes que quieren
acabar con el conservadurismo del país
social pero también político
no tengo miedo
porque creo que los policías detienen
más a los estudiantes universitarios que
a nosotros
que somos más jóvenes y los más jóvenes
son cada vez más numerosos en las
manifestaciones este amigo deploy tiene
tan sólo 14 años decidió unirse a un
movimiento que critica al ejército
aunque su propio padre es un militar
mis padres son funcionarios creen que la
economía va bien y que la educación que
recibimos es buena no entienden por qué
nos manifestamos
tengo miedo de poner a mi padre o madre
en peligro pero mis convicciones son más
fuertes que mi miedo
desde este verano cada fin de semana
salen miles a enfrentar la policía y a
pedir la salida del primer ministro
aunque el movimiento empezó en los
colegios y en las universidades se
extendió a las clases populares como en
el caso de este mototaxista que no teme
mostrar sus convicciones en el trabajo
desde hace casi 40 años de hambre
transporta clientes por las calles de
bangkok árabe de mala
todos los días cuando esta vendedora de
calle termina de agotar su reserva de
cerdo asado la llevó a su casa con su
carretilla es nuestra rutina
me interesan sus opiniones políticas
pero no las comparto del todo
dan ryan a 360 dólares al mes es el
símbolo de una tailandia muy dividida
entre ricos y pobres en 2010 participó
en el movimiento de las camisas rojas
durante dos meses campesinos pobres y
manifestantes políticos se tomaron banco
que una década después las desigualdades
se siguieron acentuando según el banco
mundial tan sólo en dos años tailandia
cuenta con dos millones de pobres más
vivo en una sola habitación
mide unos 3 metros de largo y 25 de
ancho y en total 75 metros cuadrados
y ahí vivimos tres personas los pobres
viven en los barrios marginales pero
basta con ver a los ricos que están en
unos rascacielos con ruedas me llamen
con opción tan risueña con una verdadera
seguridad social y para él solo un
régimen democrático legítimo podría
lanzar reformas socioeconómicas
profundas y luchamos contra la dictadura
para que las personas obtengan un
verdadero derecho a la igualdad e
igualdad también entre las minorías en
uno de los barrios el eje de bangkok
está drag queen también participa en el
movimiento debe hacer malabares entre su
trabajo en la noche y las
manifestaciones que llevan a cabo
durante la tarde
el agua de que mi existencia
detrás de su aire frívolo angeli lucha
por los derechos de la comunidad lgtb de
la sociedad tailandesa es tolerante con
los homosexuales pero según ella las
leyes no ella exige el derecho al
matrimonio
allí
tras bambalinas angeli a aborda el mayor
tabú de tailandia los poderes del rey
por primera vez los manifestantes se
atreven a cuestionar los ese es el
verdadero origen del movimiento
y tú
tuvimos los padres
de vuelta en las manifestaciones esta
noche un monárquico se invita al
agrupamiento con un retrato del antiguo
rey muy popular finalmente es aplaudido
unos minutos después es el turno de play
la estudiante de 16 años de subirse a la
tribuna
marinas
es decir un hamastán aquí pero también
mejor
[Aplausos]
hoy decidió lanzarse a la política sueña
con volverse diputada
hablaste muy bien
estaba muy nerviosa y se me olvidó todo
[Aplausos]
desde el golpe de estado-militar en 2014
tailandia no está acostumbrada a
semejantes reivindicaciones políticas y
sociales sea cual sea el desenlace de
este movimiento
[Aplausos]